I do feel like you've done a really good
job of mastering the internet how much
of the [__] you say online are you like
very self-aware on it's gonna go viral
this is going to be a thing I mean I
don't know I just talked some stuff I
say people don't even post it you know
what I'm saying but most of the stuff I
say they post your family so I just try
to be like just be my be yourself you
know sound like man let me be myself
keep it real and that's what's going
what's the last thing that you were the
first rapper to do
I just did some first rapper [__] the
other day
what was that first rapper [__] I did we
were somewhere I was the first rapper to
do uh damn I just did some first rapper
sheet the other day I ain't gonna come I
forgot you should do a first rapper book
like each page is like Soulja Boy was
the first rapper too yeah do this what I
just did I was someone they said you the
first rapper to do it it was real too I
forgot I'm gonna remember I forgot if
they yeah yeah it was like last week it
was last week yeah like you gotta stop
smoking so much weed if you can't
remember you feel me it's like it was
something it was yesterday I don't know
what happened [__] I prefer rapper to do
something
yeah I forgot uh so when's the tour
start August August man you know saying
yeah come on check out this you're gonna
be La Cali we're gonna be all over this
line are you going over Seasons overseas
later you know what I'm saying overseas
uh this whole run is U.S Run August
September what uh is your favorite City
to perform in that isn't in the U.S so
far because you've ever seen you've done
some wild like random places I gotta
pick one I can say something yeah do a
couple sure
Dubai for show like Dubai would be lit
can't take the weed there though but you
don't need it like Dubai so lit you not
even thinking about the weed like they
having Lamborghini you've been in Dubai
of course not they go what no I've not
been to Dubai I'd like to go you gotta
go bro you got the passport don't it
yeah of course the next time I do a show
and see hey for a rapper to take prefer
rapper [__] again for a rapper to take
care of the [__] Dubai y'all
[__] ain't took care of Dubai yet what
the [__] y'all [__] tripping okay how
long you been doing this [__] like 20
years damn yeah almost 15 15 16. that's
long enough they got me [__] up they
got us [__] up they got you [__] up
what you mean Cam ain't been to buy it
and you got the password out there say
soldier I ain't got my passport no I got
my passport got your password we going
to Dubai y'all [__] tripping so you
love Dubai where else Ferrari World okay
boom Paris Paris is great I've been
there Alpha Tower [__] Brazil I'm
saying Germany have you been to
Amsterdam Amsterdam see before we was
legal in America we was at the coffee
shops no you know about the coffee shop
yeah and the coffee Shop's getting hot
they having so much weed you're going to
Coffee Shop these people put weed in
your coffee right you could drink the
weed with coffee they having all type of
trays you pulling them out they're
having all flavors in Amsterdam in
Amsterdam like it's the trap house but
it's so cold it's cold but I love it
though did you uh partake in the red
light area of districts I'm I may have I
may have not of sorts
we may have may have uh experienced
something of the sort I heard like if
you walk through there's like walk
through that's all you got is that's
what we call it there's like a section
the walkthrough if you need a Latin girl
this is where they are there's the and
then there's the the walkthrough yeah if
I'm not mistaken they be in the windows
in there
they in the Windows like a [__]
mannequin on display would you say that
uh as a grown-up you've you've you've
never mind I'm even gonna ask a question
exactly I'm pretty sure yeah yeah I
don't wanna let's go okay I want to [__]
up either of our situations come on
um
beside okay so I know that now that
you're independent you can kind of drop
and work when you want how much music
you're trying to put out the rest of
your
oh man
I definitely want to do one more project
like I always uh drop on my birthday you
know I'm saying at least once a year
July in July do a project a year uh
so
right now
to be honest um how I'm feeling on this
album I just want to chill I want to
promote this album and Just Vibe and
just do my thing but uh we'll see
hopefully you know maybe an album come
in July if not we'll probably get one
off like at the end of the year right
I'm saying towards winter time we'll see
how this album play out are you are you
still like uh like hopping online and
gaming a lot yeah twitch.tv I just got
unbanned they had me banned on there I
was banned they banned everybody on
Twitch for a year though what'd you do I
can't I can't say what I did but you
know I'm back though you know what I'm
saying about you know what I'm saying
they just banned the kai Sonata dude
yeah it's like the biggest guy on I'm
like why would you ban your biggest
Creator and he's like a nice dude he
ain't doing nothing crazy yeah so I mean
I just feel like you know they got their
policies and stuff like that it'd be and
they'd be [__] creators I heard huh
the split that they'd be paying their
twitch is [__] up yeah but you know
it's it's a platform and you know it is
it's good to be back on that but yeah
I'll be going crazy man y'all GTA GTA we
got RP got my own server so you have
your own service so you're like full uh
role play mode on there I'm saying lit
what happens if someone breaks character
on the mic
if it's too bad like if it's if they go
too far out of it you can get banned
from the server just kick them out I'm
saying so it's like we're about to go
rob somebody and they're like hey bro my
mom's tripping real quick hold on
shut the [__]
no I'm with so
so
we go ahead and remove it will you shoot
them we're gonna have to remove you
smoke them in the game right yeah okay I
just want to make sure you know because
I know that t Grizzly should be taking
that [__] serious
he got his own server to be going crazy
yeah yeah it's it's kind of he's making
like six figures a month he's playing uh
video games yeah yeah you gotten to that
point yet are you yeah consistently see
I was at that point and then I got
banned so now you know I'm back now I'm
saying so they were [__] with you